if someone comes across and you guys
apprehend them is it apprehend like what
do you guys do you guys take them in you
guys take them into a facility do you
immediately like take them back across
the border like what kind of happens
so what's interesting about uh border
enforcement is is um I think what
happens with Middle America is there's
there's a perception I don't know if
you've been down to the Border or what
you've taken the border is but I think a
lot of America looks at the border um
Through The Eyes of what they've seen on
the news you know you look at San Diego
you look at El Paso and they show an
urbanized border you've got cities on
both side and fencing and demarcation a
lot of what the border patrol deals with
is everything in between out in the
middle of nowhere rugged mountains
desert it just
there is I've worked in places where
there's next to nothing out there in
regards to infrastructure it's just you
and your closest backup is 10 or 20
miles away and you're in the middle of
nowhere wow and so we employ and I have
to get away from the Wii because now I'm
retired but the border patrol employs a
whole Meyer out of tools um infrared
cameras ground sensors
um we've got one of the largest air
fleets in the US government and the law
enforcement realm so you've got
Blackhawks uh assortment of helicopters
unmanned aerial Vehicles so I mean
you're using all these different assets
to track so many hopefully to prevent
but to track them once they enter the
country so if you see someone say say
someone's out on patrol right on an
actual Patrol and then they see someone
Crossing into the country
um do they like tag them or like do they
what do you do like do you apprehend
them is it I mean I would it almost has
a like a freeze tag type of Hive I feel
like at a certain point it it is it's
almost like a game of cat Mouse you know
um so I'll give you two scenarios okay
in an urbanized area where we've got uh
you've got fencing or more El Paso
you're saying like El Paso um even
places like Douglas Nogales Arizona yeah
um San Diego you've got fencing or a
wall uh you know under the Trump
Administration to change from fencing to
wall right
um in those locations we've got a lot of
fixed cameras
um these are cameras that are up on on
large poles and so you've got agents
that are monitoring and watching and uh
some of the technology that plays into
these cameras also detects does change
detection so if it's watching the fence
and all of a sudden there's a change in
that picture it'll alert the operator
who then will call the agents out in the
field and then that agent he or she will
respond to the area or maybe they're
watching with binoculars and they see
them crossing over the fence through a
hole so they'll respond and then they'll
make the arrest
um it's apprehension arrest it's all the
same thing okay
um
and then the second scenario is as I
described out in the middle of nowhere
and that's more of the norm you're out
there and what happens is you may have a
ground sensor that goes off somewhere
near the border and uh you learned
psychologically as human beings you're
looking for the easiest path of
resistance so you learn the psychology
of where people are going to try to
cross okay and then you're also dealing
with one of the things that we can talk
about this shortly is you're dealing
with a Criminal element that's very
effective and I'll use the term they're
professionals at what they do smuggling
people okay and so they'll begin
trekking North into the U.S and what
agents will do is they'll find a spot
where they can make the arrest that's
it's beneficial to them
and they'll track them the sensors will
line up in such a manner that you can
track the movement of a person or a
group of people
you may use infrared scopes you may call
on uh someone up in the air to track the
group of people as they move along and
then you're rolling and make that arrest
so if there's a so it sounds like
there's a lot of capabilities to know
when and where people are coming
so it sounds great right it sounds like
all these tools all these assets
um but until you're out there and you
get a true idea of just how it really is
a needle and a haystack because some of
the areas that we work in and I'll speak
to Arizona
you have these arroyals and canyons and
brush and so you may have I may have a
camera an infrared camera that's going
to pan this way and if the ground was
flat and there was nothing to obstruct
The View
easy right but because someone can drop
into a canyon these Canyons can go for
miles or climb up into a mountain and
hide in a cave your window of
opportunity for a rest is very short so
the agents when I say they position
themselves they're finding an area where
they have great technology coverage and
they know the ins and out of that area
so when they they go to arrest these
people if they scatter and run which
happens quite often in order to work
towards to to bring them into custody
wow yeah it's got to get you out there
yeah oh you would love it
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one